-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we are gonna get to the news.
President Biden visited
an elementary school
in New Jersey today,
and spoke about his
Build Back Better agenda,
though honestly, Build Back
Better is the worst phrase
to say around a bunch of
unvaccinated kids.
"We have to build back better!
Whoa."
A group of U.S. news
organizations last week
began publishing
a series of stories
based on
internal Facebook documents
showing that
the social media platform
spreads misinformation,
incites violence,
and facilitates
human trafficking.
Even worse, it gives people
from high school
a way to get in touch with you.
Facebook is reportedly
planning to change its name
amid increased scrutiny
of the social media platform's
harmful effects.
"Hey, it worked for me,"
said stand-up comedian
Phil Jenkins.
I knew that was him!
Remember the whole show
I was saying,
"I've seen this Phil Jenkins
somewhere."
"Politico" published a report
last week
detailing President Biden's
extensive use of profanity
in private conversations
with aides.
I'm sorry, did they think
the last guy didn't curse?
He's from Queens,
he worked in construction,
and he's a terrible golfer.
That's the cursing hat trick.
If they ever got the tapes
from his meetings,
HBO couldn't air them.
During a Get Out the Vote rally
over the weekend in New York,
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
posed for a picture
with a tuba
or more likely, it just
follows him everywhere he goes.
[ Tuba playing ]
[ As Chuck Schumer ]
"We're making progress
on negotiations."
[ Tuba plays ]
Actor Brad Pitt
recently announced
that his winery will release
a new rose champagne,
though women are more interested
in his pinot.
[ Applause ]
No, don't you -- no! No!
[ Cheering ]
There is a man named
Mike Scollins
who wrote that joke,
and if we start rewarding him,
he will multiply.
Royal Caribbean recently
announced that it will offer
the longest cruise ever,
which will sail for 9 months
and visit all 7 continents,
65 countries, and 11
great wonders of the world,
and will feature at least
two new COVIDs.
"Did you get me anything,
Grandma?"
"The zeta."
McDonalds has announced
that next month,
it'll begin testing
its new meatless McPlant burger.
"In that case,
just the cash in the register,"
said the Hamburglar.
"I'm going over to Wendy's."
According to a new report
published by
"Rolling Stone" magazine,
multiple members of Congress
may have been involved
in the planning of the
January attack of the Capitol,
and I, for one, am shocked
that Congress had
anything to with it,
because it nearly worked.
And finally, amid global
supply chain delays,
toymakers are reportedly
planning to release
more small, squishy toys
this holiday season,
because more can fit
in shipping containers.
It's the same strategy
United Airlines uses
for economy class.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.